should athletes have a right to
collectively bargain yes yeah they do
right I mean it's America right thank
you
what we need is the hamburger flippers
having a right to rice bargain we need
to have union jobs for working people in
America working class people and those
are service industry jobs in restaurants
and if those are the only jobs we have
to lock we have to make those living
wage jobs and we need a new union it
looked like good news for the NFL today
what about the NBA next year I can't
even go there that's the most expensive
question I can answer right well we
don't want to do that to you this Lord
no expensive you have to eat two of
those Jets have no catering
[Applause]
you can tax me that's right all right
should we institute a mandatory war tax
when we decide to participate in a
military conflict yes what are the
panel's thoughts on California bill
oh yes the california bill I know this
requiring schools to teach the
contributions of gay lesbian bisexual
and transgender America would be funny
if you entered the sports question and
us I couldn't help but ask myself how
much of that curriculum is gonna be
speculative yeah in the sense that you
know how many out people have there been
I mean is it going to be sort of like we
got a pretty good feeling about Calvin
Coolidge we're talking about California
peso had said you have to teach in
schools now the contributions of gay
Americans like when I was a kid they
started to teach the contributions of
black Americans you know I remember like
George Washington Carver bullying of
LGBT kids bullying to death and they
have a program in the United Kingdom
where they started teaching the
contributions of people they knew to be
gay like Alan Turing who basically won
the Second World War by decoding by
breaking ROTC ciphers and then was
hounded to death by the British
government as a way of thanking him
after the war who committed suicide
right well he and they taught these they
talk okay
bullying decreased in these days yeah my
parents both fought in World War two my
mother was an Army nurse he didn't win
it all all by himself it was a big
assist knowing what the Nazis were
talking about where they were going next
what they were doing really was a huge
contribution to winning the war I'm not
saying it wasn't that contribution I'm
just saying you didn't do it oh it's a
great idea it's a and a lot of people on
the right have a problem with
acknowledging the existence of gay
people where there are children
president I think people will become gay
if gay people are acknowledged in the
presence but think about the private
work I don't disagree but think about
the process right at least in Texas to
get new book
new schoolbooks in place they go through
this whole process and you know who runs
those committees that put together the
curriculums in those books and pick the
books those far-right wing guys that you
hate and so all you're doing is just
adding [ __ ] ISM to the whole
process you know you you pick the people
who contribute and do amazing thing and
they've self-identified I'm gay you know
whatever it may be great you know but if
you try to make it a rule all you're
doing is adding more bureaucracy and the
people who are controlling the
bureaucracy are gonna use that as
leverage to do what they want to do well
the right-wingers in Texas use their
leverage to expunge fact basically focus
free and liberals can do the same in
liberal states to work facts back into
the history books
I mean I I don't always understand that
that argument about sort of like well
you don't want more bureaucracy I mean
you have to fight the good fight
somewhere and and if you're just saying
like you know let's not complicate
things let's just keep it stupid you
don't just create committees you know
gotta start some new committee as I
understand it it's just adding a noose I
mean do you have to have that in the
curriculum in the curriculum and it's
just adding a new one to a curriculum
that already exists a committee that
already exists will have one more thing
it's only a California refrain from
doing this Texas would stop doing it too
it's only gonna be detox just not the
way it's gonna work and I could think of
I mean to your point I could think of
some gay Americans who they could teach
you about Eleanor Roosevelt we know Jade
Jade guru verdure yeah we know Walt
Whitman yeah so there's three and yeah
that's about it
Abraham Lee is a growing body of
scholarship as he might gain if there's
nothing wrong with being gay speculating
that he might have been gay is no insult
to mrs. Lincoln who he wasn't very fond
of right well every guy who was not that
fond of his wife was gay
that's that's a ridiculous standard
speculating about people being gays is a
very popular pastime in America and
certainly in Hollywood happens all the
time okay here's one for the duck why do
doctors often prescribe pills to their
patients rather than diet or lifestyle
changes hey let's make money yeah well
very often when I've been in a doctor's
office I see that pharmaceutical rep
come in you know with carrying the the
suitcase and she's always hot always hot
I was just gonna say that or Jake
Gyllenhaal in that movie yes you're
right Jake Gyllenhaal hot come on you
can concede that Jake Gyllenhaal is hot
oh like I haven't noticed but also some
pills are worth the money like what
pills are you talking about like valium
well any pill that's designed to make
you feel better if you overuse it's
gonna really make you feel better so I
mean I don't know from Orient Express
you know I mean I I started to talk to
you about this out front there before
about Bill Clinton and I was kind of
making a joke about blood flow to the
penis but when people have a bad diet
that's when they need the viagra right
doc absolutely true we didn't if we were
eating right we would need to be selling
psy Alice and all the statin bloggers
and stuff like that you're 77 you don't
need it right no
[Applause]